hi everyone I'm David Griffin and now
Michael Medina we're here to bring you
arrow episode season 2 episode 15 the
promise Slade Wilson has invaded the
Queen hang the Queen residents in a very
charismatic and charming away ha ha ha
ha ha that's very beautiful art uh you
know Amanda Burnett doing a really good
job playing Slade Wilson hey create a
stroke so overall I would say this is a
big improvement over the previous family
modern family episode we had last week
well you know I know um I think I like
last week's episode a little bit more
than than you did but we can both hear
me the last couple episodes or so I've
been a little slower a good episodes I
said there were great but yeah
definitely you know not quite on par
with the previous ones and that's fine
yeah I know last week you know we aren't
the biggest fans of Laura I know a lot
of you guys as well aren't the biggest
fans either but um now that we kind of
moved on past all that and stuff this
episode just kind of smacked me in the
face yeah you know I think Manny
Burnett's doing in a wonderful job is
great and just like he just really
brings that something extra to it like
he's very charismatic yeah you know but
he's also like ridiculously ruthless
like the way he talks Oliver right about
that Oh what like grabs his armor yeah
yeah yeah but it was heavy on the
flashback just good it's something I've
wanted for like the last two seasons
like there's a heavier like a more
flashback centric episode and you got
that and that's what we won think we've
been asking me like you said we've been
asking for a flashback we got it in this
one a lot of flashback a lot of context
now we know why I mean we kind of knew
but now we know more of why you know
Slade is so angry at Oliver we know the
promised the episode is called the
promised his favorite painting in the
Oliver Queen the Queen family collection
is the promise a lot of the promise
going around just an all-around great
episode I thought you know I gay let's
just get this out of the way Diggle for
the harmony week in a row has not done
anything again he went to big belly
burger he did go to big belly here he
got some burgers for everybody everybody
could eat he tried to do something he's
right a seal sniper chelate didn't work
but he got knocked out he failed in that
so anticipated right participation of
work and we do know we saw the big
trailer you know three men show we do
know Suicide Squad is coming we know
that we have to wait two weeks because
he that'd be like stick breaks all the
time so we know that until we
you will see Diggle do more but anyway
to get getting out there from Diggle I
love the banter or just the the
chemistry between more Moira and Slade
Wilson as well I love just his like the
touching and the hahaha it was just
really feels good that's that I think
that's that's mainly because of Manny
Burnett like just like the way he
portrays Slade he's just so bad as this
character and just like you know really
kind of seeing just like him just really
torn apart you know in the flashbacks
and then you get to see how Oliver
really is taunted and no you know kind
of struggling with wanting to tell you
no se but Canton and eventually just
kind of all comes to bed so what did you
think about all the action on the
islands a lot of lot of stuff going on
the eye on this yeah it was exciting
stuff like we got to see Oliver down the
right time as well as dancing on quite
as well not quite as you know if you
want you a legit hood you know let's
let's talk about wounds will go back to
that some but one second i'll talk about
mr. red arrow you want to be legit if
you're walking through you know like
it's time to go you just do something
like this you do I'm scared that's in
fact it's all you have to do is just
like that that means you are ready to go
in action but me I don't sorry go back
to our say no all the action was great
like we go back to that guy i cant
rember same as a Russian but yeah I like
him yeah you got to see him in the Dead
Chad episode yes yeah I like Italy so I
kind of go back to that and it was an
exciting episode I've Oh finally got his
due right yeah you know um you know I
just like the way like you kind of um
you see Slade deceiving Oliver when he's
like you know we're gonna go ahead and
burn the mirakuru and obviously you know
three still had a bunch there I thought
was really well done it's something I
just I felt satisfied yeah all like just
kind of like really fleshing more that
back story about a little bit more
leading up into up until like what's
currently happening the present day I
know you know a lot of you to think hero
fans like to point out some of the
Easter eggs like let us know am I can I
try to do a little research and couldn't
find any but let us know what you think
about the the preacher I looked up his
name Flynn I believe his last his name
was and I couldn't I didn't see anything
in the DC wiki about them but let us
know if you if you you know probably
heard something the news or something
about you know this guy's going to be
somebody in the feature who is he kind
of they focus on him a lot with his mice
and you know about you know praying for
people so I'm curious if he's if he's a
character we should look out for but yea
I'd love the island stuffed that love
of how went back home and just the
episode just flowed really well and it
wasn't corny like I I know last week we
had to get a resolution between laurel
yeah you know it was nice arab needed
it's just this episode is why i love
arrow this is why i watch i really care
what the family dramas much you have
family drama beliefs mix it in with the
overall absolutely and and um i don't
wanna make it seem like i'm talking
trash mower cuz i like Roy I want to see
more of him I just feel haha I feel like
they're just teasing us like embassy
needs an outfit to the displeasure an
outfit yeah it's not work no yes not
working but like you know a few episodes
back we got that really good episode
where he's discovering his power isn't
he he meets all your training and yeah
yeah and um they just been teasing like
he'll be like in a scene or two by the
last few episodes whatnot in here he
gets a little bit more action but I'd
like to see an episode that really
focuses a little bit more on Roy right
you know entering this world because
this is a huge change yeah and used to
up until this point it's bigger Roy that
was some of the worst trying to be
incognito when they all walked into the
house like Roy comes in he's looking
this over like like I think you don't
not at the guy when you're trying to end
like trying to sneak on slave awesome
I'm sure he saw all that coming rookie
mistake yeah rookie we say he's a little
too obvious but he's learning a yes he
is um no oh no I was really satisfied
with this episode and I'm definitely
looking forward to what's you know what
else is down the line right because we
did see that little trailer yeah yeah it
shows a little bit more right for what
if you personally don't know we're
talking with a CW released a about a
little over three minute long trailer
it's called like arrow 2.5 or something
about dually the rest of the season and
what's interesting is it didn't show
some key characters my guests can't call
her a key but again no summer glau on
the trailer yeah that's really what some
curious I mean evidently she might do
like something like hey at the end and
be like this is who I really am you
gonna know the lot of you I know she's a
character in the comic books but they
still sometimes wonder I know I always
thought Talia al Ghul I don't know she's
gonna be that person I'd probably I know
she's a real character in the books but
we'll see and then we also didn't see
much of Laurel yeah I know most of you
like Laurel can just kind of go off the
show I you know but you know she's got
to play some kind
right where the lover or hater she's
there and Starling city's finest police
officer got just a cop the guy who is at
every single crime scene he's the only
cop in the city no matter where the
crime is he's there I mean he has to
have more than one police off I you know
I can't hate him though cuz he's all
great yeah I go like like last week's
episode of the kitchen chicken catch at
are like yeah he's like this show does
Cordy and campy well I mean it does
Slade Wilson many banette was super
coryell hahaha that'll be but it was
great he does such a good job of it this
is another great strong episode was a
fun episode like afterwards I was like
that was just totally fun and I don't
like to compare you know to other [ __ ]
shall rename him and everything nameless
agents of shield but um you know it's it
does it well yeah does again like I say
all the time about like opening up the
universe right off like that it's just
Center taining man it's fun yeah so I
mean sadly we have two weeks off a
two-week break until the next episode
but next week or two weeks we are going
to get the Suicide Squad yeah beagles
going to do more than go to big belly
burger and do that hopefully a shirt
hopefully roiled you more than just a
little bit of this action with the hood
to like be incognito because he needs an
outfit so this season's rolling along
we're getting towards the finish line
it's been another great season you know
so as always you can always come chat
with us and find us on think yo calm i
also have a Twitter page you know dennis
michael myself talk anything arrow and
superhero world are you liking this show
how are you sir you still watch the
Marvel agents of shield and all the DC
Marvel stuff going on right now we're at
think hero i'm at griffin de and i'm at
mr. Michael Alexis we also have enough
spots in this YouTube page here so
please you know subscribe and like this
video at sappi I think hero pro let's
have a facebook page at facebook.com
slash stink hero fans you know again be
sure social media spread the word all
things think hero video games TV film we
like it all here so yeah we'll see you
in a couple weeks
you